hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the key ideas that we find
articulated in blaze Pascal's work the
passes which has considerable influence
on some later authors who take this up
and reinterpret this is what has come to
be called the three orders and Pascal
frames these in a couple different
sections notably section 460 where he
talks about it in terms of the
traditional by that time three kinds of
sinful dispositions and also in section
793 which is in the brunch fig Edition
included in towards the back in the
these we're not quite sure where to put
them because brunchwig arranged all
these uh well not all but most of
Pascal's notes into sections and there
are a few others as well well where
these Notions are going to come up so
we're going to want to bring those
passages in so you know what what are we
talking about here what are these three
orders they are three domains three
levels of reality you could say and they
are all real and they all do have some
value so he's not you know rejecting one
in favor of the other two or another one
but they are distinct from each other
and there's a kind of
incommensurability between them an
incommensurability not just in terms of
the human subjects who Orient themselves
Within These but also an
incommensurability of value as we're
going to see so what are these three
orders let's start with the bottom one
this is what we could call the order of
the flesh the word that Pascal uses you
know Shar uh flesh is is uh the
corresponding English term and and this
is you know corresponding to Starks in
uh Greek like in the New Testament and
then we have body as well the core right
so this is the level at which people are
primarily
orienting themselves to the physical
world that we see and to being a body
among other things in that very world
and then on a higher level we have the
order of the Mind the espri at certain
points as we'll see Pascal will talk in
terms of intellect right as opposed to
just the entire mind but it's fine to
call it the mind this is a general term
in French for the the part of us that
that does the thinking as opposed to the
body so we've already got you know
something that will be very familiar to
those who studied modern philosophy
particularly contemporaries of Pascal
like Rene Descartes we've got a
distinction between the mind and the
body and the mind is more valuable and
incommensible with the body and yet
we've got a third level and this is you
know you could say rather distinct or
something that Pascal is adding to the
mix we have the order of what he's going
to call in one place the will now this
is going to present a few problems that
we'll look at but the Volante right the
faculty of choice but not just the
faculty of choice the part of us that
turns our attention that chooses what to
do with the mind and the body so this is
quite important he'll also talk about
this level as being one of Charity which
we can translate as love war if you like
you can use the cognit charity and so
this is something that is yet higher and
in commensurable with these other orders
so let's actually take a look at the
passages
he begins 460 with talking about the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
Pride Etc so what are we talking about
there well these are sort of three
overarching dispositions that if you
look in Christian thought these will be
ways of classifying how people go wrong
the lust of the flesh includes a lot the
lust of the eyes you might say how do
your eyes actually feel lost well you
want to look at stuff and by extension
you want to think about things curiosity
is Central to that and then the pride of
life he just talks about Pride or gay at
this point but it's traditionally talked
about as the pride of of life and so all
three of these are distinctive ways in
which people go wrong but they're also
leading Clues
to how we can arrange things he says
there are three orders of things the
flesh the spirit and the will and then
he starts talking about the kinds of
people that correspond to this and we'll
have to look at not just section 460 in
order to flesh this out but let's start
with that he talks about the carnal
right uh they shower now those who are
primarily oriented by their flesh
Kings the rich
um in section 793 he'll also talk about
captains right and captains we could
think of this as anybody who's using
power and then he says also all of the
people of the flesh too Legend right and
so this is you know all of those sorts
of people what is uh orienting them
he'll he'll say that they have the body
as their object and what does he mean
the body their own single body no the
whole realm of bodily things they're
interested in exercising power and
making wealth they're interested in
enjoying physical pleasure or perhaps
avoiding physical pain they are
fundamentally preoccupied with matters
of the Flesh of the body so that's one
level
what about the order of the mind which
could include Pascal himself at an
earlier stage of his life and remember
he's a you know great mathematician who
makes contributions to a theory of
probability and all sorts of other
interesting things as well he's kind of
a social critic you could say uh in this
work as in his earlier Works he's very
interested in rhetoric as we know so
what are these people all about he says
now the translation here is inquirers
and scientists and so inquirers are the
uh those who have curiosity right and
scientists the Savant right the the
knowers the people who are
orienting themselves it's not just the
Sciences or if we understand Sciences we
have to understand in a very broad sense
so it would include mathematics and
philosophy and literature and rhetoric
and all of these other things as well as
the natural and what we call the social
sciences and these people are oriented
by research by thinking by using their
intellects they're oriented by inquiry
or curiosity in in French right they
want to figure things out they want to
understand things
not a bad thing right and he will talk
about these uh at a certain point as uh
you know the the great Geniuses the
economy the great minds have their
empire their place right uh their
greatness their Victory their uh loosed
their their you could call it
appealingness or attractiveness right
and you know they're Rising above the
order of the flesh because this
this stuff is more interesting for them
they want knowledge that's what they're
seeking I mean there's a certain kind of
pleasure in knowledge you could say but
they're not seeking out physical
pleasure they're seeking out the
enjoyment of something mental something
intellectual
then we have this highest level
this is the people that Pascal actually
calls the wise
and you might say well don't they belong
in the order of Mind well for Pascal
true wisdom genuine wisdom isn't just a
matter of the mind or the intellect or
science or something like that as a
matter of fact humble people can be wise
simple people can be wise and they are
looking for wisdom that's what is
orienting them right and what is their
object so as opposed to
knowledge or you know the things of the
flesh the body
he says that it is righteousness Justice
in French which we could translate as
justice but I think righteousness has a
good connotation here because it frames
it in terms of like the justice of
fitting yourself into not just the
cosmos but in relation to God and to
other people and he actually tells us
that these people okay he brings it up
in terms of the pride of life but there
is a proper sort of Pride that they can
have he says this is in section 460 God
must Reign Over all all must be brought
back to him and things of the flesh lost
rain especially the rules you could say
right in intellectual matters inquiry in
wisdom Pride specially
so there is a kind of Pride that would
be the right so Court he says that not
that a man cannot boast of wealth or
knowledge
but it is not the place for pride in
granting to a person that they are
learned it's easy to convince them that
they're wrong to be proud the proper
place for pride
is in wisdom
why now here's where he says something
very interesting that reveals that
there's this is this order is open to
the above right the proper place for
pride is in wisdom for it cannot be
granted to a person that they have made
themself wise and that they are wrong to
be proud for that is right God alone
gives wisdom and that is why who Glory
should glory in God he says right
so you know this is this is quite an
interesting set of points that he's
making if we look at
uh section 793 there's some additional
things that are being added to this he
tells us that and here's where you know
this invisibility this una inability to
grasp what's going on with the higher
order he tells us that the greatness of
the people of the mind is invisible to
Kings to rich people to captains to all
the people of the flesh they you know
they can have some dim inkling of it
they can certainly use them but they
can't grasp the greatness
of these people they can only understand
it in pragmatic ways so the science if
we want to use the Natural Sciences that
these people can uh engage in and you
know produce advances in can only be
understood in terms of making money or
making war or providing Pleasures or you
know managing people it can't be
understood in its own terms he goes on
and he says the greatness of wisdom
which is nothing without God is
invisible to the fleshly people and to
the people of mine why because these are
three
different orders in terms of their
nature or genre
and he goes on and he says each of these
has their empire each of them has their
things that they're good at the holy
people they sat have their empire
their Victory their attractiveness which
has no need of uh fleshly or bodily
greatnesses or spiritual where they
don't have any sort of connection these
in adding themselves aren't going to
contribute anything and he says they are
seen by God and the angels not by the
bodies or by curious minds God Alone
suffices to them and he's going to go on
as well and tell us some other very
interesting things about this as well so
he tells us that
um
all of the bodies the firmament so the
the cosmos itself right the Stars the
earth and its kingdoms
are not
worth had don't have value of the least
of Minds all that physical stuff that's
awesome
but just one single mind is worth more
than that so there's an
incommensurability here going on he goes
on and he says
um you know why because this mind knows
all of that and itself
the body doesn't
what else all of the bodies together all
of the minds together and all of their
Productions are not worth or not of the
same value
as the least movement of Charity or love
this is of a infinitely a higher order
he says and you know he says
of all the bodies together
you cannot you know get a single thought
this is impossible it's of another order
of all the bodies and Minds together you
can't draw a single movement of true
charity this is impossible it's of
another order it is Supernatural so this
is this third order is where we really
connect up with God not just in having
knowledge of God or being part of a
cosmos that God created and there's a
few other things that we need to say to
fill this out so one is right after 460
he's going to follow this up by saying
the three lusts have made three sects
and the philosophers have done no other
thing than follow one of the three lusts
right which implies that we can go wrong
even on this highest level right and a
little bit earlier in the work in
section 283 he's going to talk again
about order and he's going to say
against the objection the scripture has
no order and he's going to bring in a
term that has just been you know brought
up in a very famous way earlier in
section 277 about the heart
so he says the heart has its own order
what is the order of the heart the
highest level right the intellect has
its own which is by principle and
demonstration the heart has another
and what is this uh highest level it is
the order of Charity of love
in French
so what we've got I mean you could say
well so does all of this take place only
on the highest order no in the human
being the will the heart and love can
take place at all of these levels true
love true charity is only at the highest
level and we human beings are very
subject to getting all of these things
mixed up and screwed up and you know you
don't have to be a pascal you can go all
the way back to Augustine love can be
disordered can't it right and we're
always loving the heart the will is
constantly oriented by love and the will
extends to all of this as the heart
encompasses all of this and ultimately
it should be oriented within and by the
things of this highest order keeping
everything you could say in its proper
perspective so this is a very important
distinction that Pascal is going to make
that should allow human beings in his
view to properly understand and Orient
themselves in a world in which there are
many people primarily focused on the
body and the flesh others who go beyond
that to the realm of the mind or the
intellect and yet others who go even
further with the help of God